let's get more on the legal side of this
from cbs news election law expert david
becker he joins us now david good
morning to you
impeachment of course is a political
process not a legal one but the legal
boundaries still matter
so with that in mind what did you think
of the house
democrats case yesterday
well they laid out a very strong case
yesterday they laid out
the why which is the big lie the
president whipping his supporters into a
frenzy for months and months going back
to the spring
about how the election was going to be
rigged even though we knew that was
false
second they laid out the what the harm
the incredible damage done
to congress and the capital that day
uh january 6th but probably most
importantly
they they laid out the how which is that
the president
every time he had called his supporters
to a place to michigan to the capitol to
or to an election official's house
to texas to d.c on december 12th his
supporters showed up
and they often showed up armed and there
was often violence that ensued
and so that case is very very strong
right now so let's shift to the
president's defense speech of course is
free in this country but it is not
unlimited
how do the president's lawyers deal with
the fact that he repeated this election
lie about it being stolen from the
american people
and then his supporters showed up to
take it back
yeah it's going to be a difficult case
for the defense in this case um this is
a political trial and there are a lot of
senators who want to find a reason to
acquit and
it's going to be difficult for them to
really make the case that the president
didn't know this could happen didn't
want this to happen
and then of course he didn't act for
hours while it was ongoing even though
he was begged repeatedly including by
members of his own party
so they're likely going to try to
distract they're going to bring up some
constitutional
issues most of them are frivolous things
like the chief justice not
presiding over the event but that is
that's a frivolous issue that is uh most
the
vast consensus is that that is fine in
this case it's a former president not
the president
and so we're there's they're going to
try to distract with
issues related to perhaps some what
about is unlike other
other times when democrats or others
have tried to have said things that were
probably
not the same david quickly we've
mentioned it's a political trial could
it at some point be a criminal trial
uh yes this is not an uh either or there
could absolutely be criminal charges the
prosecution of a former president is not
something that a prosecutor will take up
on a whim though
they're going to look at this very very
carefully over time and in fact you
heard the president's lawyers suggest
that the proper remedy for this
it was a little bit odd to hear them say
this is a criminal prosecution of the
former president
all right david becker thank you very
much and we will bring you our coverage
of day three of the historic second
impeachment trial
of former president trump in a cbs news
special report we expect the senate to
begin around noon eastern
that would be 9 a.m pacific